in an exclusive interview apple ceo tim
cook is revealing new details about the
racial equality initiative
the tech giant launched last summer
after the killing of george floyd now
the company is spending 100 million
dollars
to expand opportunities for communities
of color and technology and
entrepreneurs
cook and his vice president that's lisa
jackson who heads this initiative
are building new learning centers and
teaming up with historically black
colleges and universities so apple
closed down part of its store here in
new york the other day
so we could talk with them at the
company's headquarters in silicon valley
let's start with the propel center how
will the propel center work
well it's going to serve essentially the
100 or so
hbcus that are across the u.s it will
have
students that come there and so think of
it as an
innovation hub and we'll work on things
from coding to machine learning
to creativity to entertainment arts but
you're focusing on the hbcus you're
going
morehouse spelman the morehouse school
of medicine
clark university it's about giving
people opportunity
i can't wait to see students that are
able to enjoy
the innovation hub the propel center
what exactly will they get there tim
you're going to learn things about
machine learning you're going to learn
things about
coding you're going to learn about
entrepreneurship
a lot of the things that we do here will
be in the curriculum
there were you a good student tim when
you were in school were you a good
student well you know
you know gail i tried to be i'm going to
take that as a yes but go ahead
i tried to be
before she came to apple in 2013
lisa jackson served as president obama's
epa administrator
now she's running all of the tech
giant's environmental and social policy
efforts
hbcus have a history of turning out the
leaders in our community the propel
center
will be a place for all hbcu students
and the surrounding community it's a
place for
apple and other companies to plug in
to the hbcu talent pool we know that the
talent is already there
we know these students are trying to do
what every student does
propel themselves to a better future and
a better life
i like the word propel center because it
makes me think off like a rocket ship
i like that i agree the name propel
center is exactly that
this is meant to be a little bit of
winds under their sails
now i'm excited about the city of
detroit
detroit has 50 000 small businesses
owned by black and brown people there is
a concentration
of strivers in detroit who are trying to
build their city back
and so we decided to bring to that area
the first ever in the united states app
developer academy
we do want to give some extra lift to
black and brown developers
it's a fantastic footprint there we want
to
provide people a mechanism to learn to
code to learn how to write world-class
apps
i understand that there's an application
process what do you have to see on an
application that makes you say you know
what alexis you're in
desire creativity a level of
interest you want to feel that desire
of someone who really wants to make a go
at this
we have one program that's focusing on
people that
have not studied coding at all do you
think anybody can learn to code tim
it's so intimidating to me do you think
anybody can learn to do it
i do can you do it can you i can
you know i did it in school once you
start you recognize
that it's just another language but
apple isn't just building the next
generation of minority tech
entrepreneurs it's also supporting
today's visionaries
through a 10 million dollar investment
in harlem capital
that's a fund whose goal is to back a
thousand companies
founded by women or people of color in
the next 20 years
tim i want to know what is it about you
that you even noticed
or paid attention to systemic racism is
it the way you were raised did you
see it early or what is it clearly
i think anybody that was alive in the
periods of time that i've been alive in
the
in the 60s and 70s and growing up in
that period you
first hand witnessed it when i was five
years old
john lewis was beaten on the edmund
pettus bridge
when i was eight years old the riots at
stonewall happened
both of these changed the course of time
and changed the course of my life as
well
when you either experience those sort of
things or read about those things
and then apply them to what you're
seeing today
there was systemic racism there is
systemic racism
and it's not going to go away unless we
do something about it
cook is speaking out about the current
political situation as well
he was shocked by last week's violence
in washington
it was a very very sad and shameful day
probably like you i couldn't believe
what i was seeing either i felt like i
was
in some other form of reality or
something
it really affects you here
i think it's key that people be held
accountable for it
this is not something that should skate
cook is holding accountable the social
media app parlor
it's popular with the far right claiming
it failed to remove language inciting
violence from its platform
apple removed it from the app store over
the weekend effectively preventing
anyone with an iphone from using it
parlor has some issues with moderation
there are some
incitement to violence examples on there
and they need to step it up on the
moderation and i'm our hope is that they
do that
and get back on the store oh so they
could get back on the store
they could yes we suspended them we did
not ban them
because the ceo as you know he's raising
issues about his right to the first
amendment
what do you say about that concern we
have
terms of service for our app store
and some of those terms of service he's
in violation of
all we're asking gail is that he meet
the terms of service
i want to know your goals in 2021 for
the company
for yourself for the country for me it's
always the same
whether what year it is it's to do as
much as i can to help other people
and enrich their lives that's apple's
goal
for the country i hope that we enter a
stage in our country where we're back to
bipartisanship
yeah make no mistake about tim cook this
is a man who cares deeply about his
company
cares deeply about the country he was
very much affected by the
the senseless killing of george floyd
that we all watched in real time
he put out a letter to his employees at
that time speaking about how he was
feeling
he said we must do more we have to
create change we have to re-examine our
own views and actions in light of the
pain
into the black community we see you you
matter your lives matter and this is a
way of making sure that
he is heard it's a one it's an amazing
thing that they're doing at apple
major corporations like apple now are
are critical in driving change in this
country
in many cases change is starting at a
corporate level and he's leading he's
leading that he's leading that charge
and i'm glad corporations are are
standing up i would only point out
that the gov the government of this
country led policies that created this
inequality